-Guys, as I said earlier,
yesterday was President Biden's
State of the Union address.
And after the speech, I saw a
lot of politicians reacted
with statements of their own.
Let's take a look.
It's time for
"State of the Union Reactions."
-♪ "State of
the Union Reactions" ♪
-Alright,
let's see what everyone
had to say about Biden's speech.
First up, we have
Senator Richard Blumenthal.
He said...
Up next, we have
Senator Mark Kelly. He said...
-Wow.
-That's unfortunate.
-Why?
-Next, we have
Congressman Rick Crawford.
He said...
♪ I used to call her Mary ♪
Here's Senator
Tommy Tuberville.
After Biden's speech, he said...
Kids, you want to get a photo?
-Hey!
Let's go down to Tuberville.
-Next up, we have
Congressman Earl Blumenauer.
He said...
-Wow.
-Finally, we have
Congressman August Pfluger.
He said...
There you have it, everybody.